[music]
yes yes and not only in russia but of course the
former soviet soviet union yes
a lot of people not only in ukraine but
in kazakhstan many many countries
speak russian and it is one of the
international most important tender
international languages in the world spani
h slave  i when i show when
i heard i was happy this time until
10 years ago i focused a lot on
russian language unfortunately i
don't study russian russian language for a very long time
when i was in ukraine 2 times there i
tried one skype knife at all you hear
in russian  and therefore, unfortunately, the accuracy of the
Russian language needs
effort and when I don’t
study Russian for a very long time, of course, I will
score owls and make a lot of mistakes
when it doesn’t matter to me, I will show
people
that I now speak with difficulties, but
anyway for me it
’s great  pleasure every time
when I can speak Russian and this
does not interfere with our communication in the least, I
understand you perfectly, so I
will also close that there are no mistakes  you don’t need to, they
won’t be without them, but this should not interfere with communication in any way,
and even if I focus on
Russian,
I’m afraid, I’m not afraid, but I know that I
will never speak DSP with errors,
never, never,
and in English  i have been doing
international business for many years for people from
sweden
from germany not to mention but the japanese are not
the best in
english but people from sweden to germany they
speak very good english and
still there will always be mistakes and there will be
mistakes that reflect habit
habits from their mother tongue of course i
know here in canada we have a co-worker
from 1
i am from russia he is russian pagan
from elected david beat the soviet
union and he speaks
perfect english perfect and he can
explain everything and understand everything and speak like
every normal  Canadian but he does not
exist he says freely oblige and
and everyone understands and
and he is very but I want that anyway I
would like if I would erase now  .  in
Russian
I will I want to study with you so that I
say I would speak exactly in Russian
but still you will never give
mistakes without errors and it doesn’t matter it
doesn’t bother me I have great
pleasure in learning the Russian language
absolutely everything depends on your  goals you
don’t get a job as a
translator for the united
nations before or you are not a translator of the
president in this case it’s probably worth the
extra effort to speak
without mistakes I live in America for 10 years
I have been studying English since I was five years old and
still I’m sure what I’m doing  a large
number of mistakes, it’s just that
sky-educated people don’t speak,
and Russian people also speak in their native language
and make a large number of mistakes, of
course, not second-hand, for example, as
foreigners would make, but the
emphasis on the meaning of words, and so on, the language
is something deep, bottomless, I don’t
know  a huge team, go ahead, so
pull it and a terrible question if I ask you,
I want to say, well, what do I want  u
make less mistakes how what is your
suggestion how is it like a playboy and
how can you help me tell them
more often komi my recipe is this i was
recommended to hire a teacher
better to give a person who can
explain your mistakes or at least
native speakers who are not your
spouse spouse close  another
because it causes a conflict
and ask you to communicate regularly and
write down your mistakes and then tell you about them
and then in my opinion you will need
to consciously pay attention to these
mistakes are unacceptable make a mistake in
cases constantly the same thing as
ours  the mistakes are usually the same, yes,
wear some kind of ossified ones and you yourself
should stop saying so stop,
but here you need to do it like this, that is,
you need awareness on when we turn on our
heads and gradually train ourselves
to prevent this mistake from me
that is, this is such a recipe do you think
tell me yes but I manage I don’t I
understand Russian grammar  but I understand everything I
read not I read a lot I understand but
when I said I can’t when
when I say if I have to think about the
right at a level that I understand, I need
points and on this I ca
n’t think about this, it means how to develop
the whole lecture yes and what you said it is
this it is true I don’t know
any slave language I will speak over the
Internet and each time I will write
lists of my mistakes you know and some
and I can read there will be written and
only in the list and  november medal i
have a recording of this discussion i
see that every basket deed i make the
same mistakes and every time we have to
say no it is not so it is so and every
next lecture
service discussion lesson i will do the
same though i know  although she got me
out of correctly properly no and how how
it is how to say it and I flex since it
is corrected by
steve but it seems to me that one should not forget the
impregnation awareness and repetition yes that
is good the second time make the same
mistake 3 1 5 but  at 7 you yourself
will stop and say not so that it’s not so, but
that is, some kind of control
should still be given then what you say,
well, plus I actually agree with
your method, you say things, the language
needs to get used to and it’s necessary to listen
read so that it becomes native until
your
ear catches itself thinking so that's not
it I'm saying something wrong also
an absolute combination to a huge
amount of listening reading and
self-control of awareness and then in the end it
becomes something
natural something  then it’s natural for you
and in the end I think that you should not be afraid and
leg
to admit that you wouldn’t, I admit that I
won’t say we are behind the nets,
therefore, but I also know that, as you
said, it’s a little by little by little
gradually I will have a new habit
for example
it’s the most-most simple it’s ships to the
instrument with
us where you are because it’s a
little bit different ok and and it’s
difficult but with you from us and it’s 100 and
there will be in my brain  r phrases that
sound natural and the amount of this
phrase are natural phrases inside who
is there correctly constructions the
number will increase a little bit
or I think that ray of course it
should be noted a column as
I will try and
correct something or you should find something that
will happen in physics but  there is
complexity so you don’t have to
worry too much you need to understand what
to work on, but a little husband doesn’t know
that he is making a mistake to forgive you or
ask you it will be right to ask you,
but my students on the C tax
say to ask you if I don’t tell you what
it is  not true, they don’t know about it,
so the beauty of the teacher is that
he can point out what to work on
and, in principle, all the same,
but I hope that next time when we
will speak Russian in a year, I
can get a little bit of you
speak Russian  can get even better yes but
still i think that your i saw your
channels very good very motivating this
is your most thank you bol  Thank you so much very
nice picking up
[music]